قالت قيادات استخباري استخباراتيه وعسكريه
اسرائيليه ان ايران تخوض حرب استنزاف عبر
وكلائها في المنطقه ضد اسرائيل الموقف
الاسرائيلي الذي اعقب تنفيذ حزب الله
اللبناني مناوره عسكريه في بلده عرنت
الجنوبيه حاكت اختطاف جنود واقتحام
مستوطنات رد عليه مسؤول ايراني بالقول ان
اي اعتداء عسكريا اسرائيلي ضد طهران
سيقابل برد واسع وغير مسبوق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دوافع التحريرات
الاسرائيليه من اندلاع حرب كبرى في
المنطقه وعلى اكثر من جبهه ما هي الرسائل
وما مغزى توقيتها وما دلالات التركيز
الاسرائيلي على سوريا كمنطقه حرب محتمله
منعكاسات فشل المسار الدبلوماسيه في حل
ازمه الاتفاق النووي الايراني على مسار
التصعيد المحتمل في المنطقه والى اي حد ما
زال الطرفان الايراني والاسرائيلي يلتزمان
بقواعد الاشتباك والردع في ظل تراشق
الاتهامات بينهما بتجاوز قواعد اللعبه في
الفتره الاخيره وما مالات هذا التصاعد هذا
التوتر وتصاعد لهجه التهديد بين الجانبين
وهل يمكنه ان يفضي الى مواجهات على اكثر
من جبهه وما تاثيره على استقرار الاوضاع
في المنطقه في ضمن انشغال الامريكيين غربي
بالصراع مع روسيا والصين
[موسيقى]
على لساني اكثر من مرجعيه استخباريه
وعسكريه صدرت عن اسرائيل لا تحذيرات من
احتمالات اندلاع حرب وصفتها تل ابيب
بالكبرى في المنطقه خلاصه صنعتها متابعه
عن كثب لمؤشرات قدرت معها تل ابيب ان
طهران تخوض ضدها حرب استنزاف تسعى لتطويق
الدوله العبريه بوكلاء ينتظرون ساعه الصفر
رئيس شعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه اهرون حليفه قال ان الامين
العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر الله
قريب جدا من ارتكاب خطا يقود الاوضاع
المتدهوره في المنطقه الى حرب كبيره
لو قامت الخاصه حسن نصر الله بعد مرور 17
عاما على الخطا الذي ارتكبه عام 2006 يريد
تغيير الموازين امام اسرائيل وهو قريب جدا
من ارتكاب خطا سيؤدي الى تدهور الاوضاع
بالمنطقه ووصولها لحرب كبرى واذا ما اضفنا
الى ذلك الثقه بالنفس التي ابداها الرئيس
الاسد في اللقاء مع ولي العهد السعودي
وسماحه باستخدام مسيرات ايرانيه من اراضي
سوريا كل هذا يجعل احتمال الحرب عاليا في
المنطقه وعلينا ان نكون مستعدين لذلك
المستوى السياسي الاسرائيلي لم يتاخر وعلى
اعلى مستوى عن المساهمه في هذا الخطاب
الرسمي الاسرائيلي حيث قال الرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو سنفاجئ ايران
مؤكدا ان اسرائيل ستفاجئ كل اعدائها
في المقابل قال مسؤول ايراني للجزيره ان
اي اعتداء عسكري على المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه سيقابل برد واسع وغير مسبوق
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من تل ابيب عكيف
الدار المحلل السياسي والاستراتيجي
الاسرائيلي سيد عقيل دار اهلا وسهلا بك
هناك تصريحات تعد صدرت من الجانب
الاسرائيلي واخرها ما سمعناه من بنيامنه
نتنياهو الذي قال ان اسرائيل
ستفاجئ ايران ما مغزى هذه التصريحات وهل
نحن على وجهك ان نشاهد تصعيدا
عسكريا كبيرا كيف نفهم هذه التصريحات
في الواقع اعتقد ان عليكم ان تسالوا ما هو
السياق هذه التصريحات
وما هو التوقيت هذه التصريحات
اود ان اضيف الى هذه المعادله
اجتماع القمه في جده
هو العلاقات الوثيقه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وتقربهم
تقرب بين الرياض وطهران واعتقد ان الرساله
الموجهه ليس فقط لايران وهي ليست مجرد
تحرك او موقف استراتيجي من نتنياهو بل
لابد ان ظل ذلك ظل السياق المحلي المشكله
هي ان هذا ان سوء فهم الطرف الاخر
وان الايران قد ترقد ذلك بشكل جدي رغم
اننا نعلم جميعا اعتقد مشاهديكم وانتم
وانا نعرف بانه دون دعم او علق لفظ النظر
من قبل واشنطن فان اسرائيل لا استطيع ان
تحقق شيئا كبيرا عسكريا ضد ايران يعني
تعتقد انه يجب عدم المبالغه في هذا الامر
تقول يجب ان لا تفهم يفهمه الجانب الاخر
بشكل خا طئ كيف يجب ان يفهمه الجانب الاخر
يعني اذا كان هذا ليس تهديدا بحرب وشيكا
فما هو
الواقع الرساله هي ايضا
موجهه الى
الى اجتماع المجموعه السبعه جي 7
بانه اذا لم تقوم بتحرك ما دبلوماسيا او
عسكريا او فرض عقوبات او اذا ما وصلت غض
النظر عما يحصل في ايران فان اسرائيل
ترتكب شيء غير موجود حاليا غير مذكور ولكن
اسرائيل لا تستطيع ان تقوم اي شيء دون
الولايات المتحده ولكن كل شيء ممكن في
الوقت ذاته وهذا يعني انما تقوم به
اسرائيل في سوريا
وفي السنوات الماضيه
بمهاجمه الاهداف الايرانيه
وهذا يعني كانه يهاجم وايران وفاه فان
اسرائيل احيانا قد توصل الى السوق فهم ليس
ما يتعلق بضعف المحلل
الايراني ايضا حزب الله فهم ينظرون الى ما
يحصل في اسرائيل من ناحيه السياسيه
ونستطيع ان نقول ان ذلك روايات وحكايه
يمكن نعتبر ذلك الثوره سياسيه ولكن سوء
الفهم مهما الطرف الاخر يؤدي الى كارثه
تتنافى مع مصالحهم وهذا يعني ان لبنان ليس
لديها مصلحه اليه في اي مواجهه عسكريه اما
وكذلك لاسرائيل ولكن قد تحصل الامور في
الشرق الاوسط وخاصه على الحدود
الاسرائيليه دون وجود نيه لذلك ودون
التخطيط مسبق وقد يكون ضحك ضد مصلحه
الطرفين او جميع الاطراف شكرا لك كيف
الدار المحل السياسي والاستراتيجي
الاسرائيلي
بتعميق النقاش معنا في هذه الحلقه من
واشنطن
كبير الباحثين في معهد صوفان للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والعمله الدولي ومن طهران
الدكتور فؤاد اسدي استاذ الدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه في جامعه طهران
الدكتور كيف تتلقى طهران هذه التصريحات
الاسرائيليه وكما قلت اخر هذه التصريحات
كان ليامين نتنياهو الذي قال ان اسرائيل
ستفاجئ ايران
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
فان الاسرائيلين دائما كانوا يهددون
بمهاجمه ايران لعقود السيد نتنياهو يزعم
ان ايران تنوي الحصول على سلاح النوويه
قبل سنوات عديده وهذا الامر لا يمثل اي
صعوبه لايران ايران
لديها برنامج نووي سلمي متوسع ويتزايد
وامكانيات ايران العسكريه تتزايد وايضا
الملاحه الايرانيه الان
قامته باستخدامه بناء سفن بحريه محليه
الصنع واجابه العالم وايضا هي هنالك هنالك
مزاع ام ببيع ايران لمسيرات لروسيا وليس
هنالك اي شك اذا ما كان هنالك هجوم على
ايران قالوا قال قاده ايران ان سيكون هناك
رد فعل من ايران بالتالي لغه الخطاب هذه
التي تاتي من اسرائيل ليست جديه حقا
بالفعل ليست جديه السيد كانت كوزمان
وكيف تنظر واشنطن الى هذه التصريحات برايك
هل هناك رؤيه موحده مشتركه في التحذير من
حرب قد تكون وشيكه هل تشترك
تل ابيب واشنطن في هذه الرؤيه
هل تشترك تل ابيب وواشنطن في هذه الرؤيه
اذا قد نعود لسيد كوتشمان في في وقت لاحق
الاسرائيليون تحدثوا عن ساحات عده يمكن ان
تكون
مسرحا لمواجهه اسرائيليه ايرانيه في رايك
لماذا يركزون على
الجبهه السوريه
انجاز ان نقول اكثر من غيرها
دكتور سؤال لك
تعرفون فان هذا هذه الجبهه هي التي
يعتقدون ان بامكانهم ان يستهدفوا اهدافا
ايرانيه وان يقوم بمهاجمه ايران داخل
لانهم هجمت ايران داخل الاراضي الايرانيه
سيكون الامر مكلفا للاسرائيلين بالتالي هم
يستهدفون المصالح الايرانيه خارج ايران
ايران
تستجيب وترد
عن طريق مهاجمه الاسرائيليين وعن طريق دعم
منظمات المقاومه مثل حماس وجهاد الاسلامي
وايضا منشات المسيرات والصواريخ التي
تستخدمها فصائل المقاومه وتستخدم اما
تجهزها ايران او ان التكنولوجيا يتم
اعطائها من ايران الى تلك المنظمات
بالتالي عندما يهاجموا الاسرائيليون ايران
ايران تردوا بطرق مختلفه هذا ما قد قامت
به ايران خلال السنوات الماضيه نعم ولكن
لماذا التركيز على سوريا هذا هو السؤال
لماذا تعتقد الامريكيون يتحدثون عن سوريا
اكثر من من غيرها
كما تعرفون ما حصل خلال الاسابيع والاشهر
الماضيه ان سوريا تعادت الى الجامعه
العربيه
والى حضن الدول العربيه التي
رحبت الدول العربيه بعوده سوريا هذا شيء
لا تريده اسرائيل
سوريا كانت احدى الجبهات والدول التي
واجهت الاعتداء الاسرائيلي وحقيقه ان هذه
الحكومه كانت تقاوم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تم الترحيب بها مره اخرى شيء لا يرضي
الاسرائيلين وحقيقه ان ايران ايضا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه قاموا بتطبيع
العلاقات واستئناف العلاقات مع بعضهما
البعض وحقيقه ان الخيار الذي تمتلكها
اسرائيل في مساله مواجهه الايرانينا قد
قلت وهذا امر يقلق اسرائيل بالتالي هنالك
الكثير من الاشخاص في الغرب ادركوا ان
الاسرائيليين هي دوله تمييز عنصري
الناس في الولايات المتحده واوروبا يدركون
ان حكومه ان حكوماتهم تمولو حكومه ودوله
تمييز عنصري وهذا شيء لا يعجبهم وهذا يطلق
الاسرائيليين ايضا دعنا نشرك السيد القدس
من مره اخرى في النقاش وهو يسمعني الان
اامل ذلك كنت اقول كيف تنظر واشنطن الى
هذه التصريحات التي تاتي من اسرائيل والى
اي مدى يمكن ان تكون مقلقه وهل تشترك في
نفس الرؤيه التي نسمعها من نتنياهو وغيره
في الاداره الاسرائيليه
شكرا جزيلا الولايات المتحده وموقوفه قد
تغير قليلا منذ ان قام كبار مسؤولين
نحو التفهم مخاوفه وقلق اسرائيل وان
اسرائيل لديها الخيار اذا ما قرر ذلك اذا
كان هناك اذا قررت ان الخطر وجودي عليها
فانها قد توجه هجمات وان ايران وان الضيف
الاسرائيلي كانت بدايه لاحظ بشكل صحيح باء
اسرائيل ولايه المتحده
سيناقشان هل ان اسرائيل تقوم باي هجمات
وبالتالي اعتقد
الموقف في الامريكي ما زال
بان البرنامج النووي الايراني وانها مشكله
عالميه ومشكله وان ايران مشكله اقليميه
وعالميه وما زال لديها وجود كبير في منطقه
الخليج الفارسي والمنطقه
وان الولايات المتحده كلها الراي او الدور
او قد تتخذ عملا لو حصل عمل عسكري خاصه ضد
الاراضي الايرانيه اما اذا كان الامر في
سوريا كاقرب الى سوريا وان اسرائيل توجه
ضربات في سوريا ولكن هذا يترك للراي وقرار
اسرائيل اما اذا نتحدث عن توجيه ضربات
داخل ايران نفسها فذلك امر الولايات
المتحده بالتاكيد لابد ان يكون يكون ان
يجري بشكل منسق معها واطلاعها ومناقشتها
قبل ان يحصل دون ان يكون ذلك مفاجاه
الولايات المتحده الضيف الايراني مثل سيد
فوتون في روسيا يطلق الكثير تهديدات
ويتحدث عن تهديدات كثيره على غرار السيد
بوتين فان ضيفكم في طهران ليس في موقع
يسمح ان يواجه اتهام ظل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا هذا الشيخ خطر خطر جدا ان
تهدد الولايات المتحده فالذين يطلقون
تهديدات مثل هذه عاده يؤسفون على مثل هذه
في نهايه المطاف التهديدات هي موجهه
لاسرائيل في المقام الاول وان ايران قادره
على
الرد وبالتالي هل هذه طبول حرب تقرع بين
حين واخر
الامريكيون اين هم من المسار الدبلوماسي
لمنع حرب كهذه ام انهم الان يعني يفسحون
المجال للغه القوه
الولايات المتحده حفظت طريق ان اخر
للايران ولايات المتحده حاولت ان تعيد
الحياه الاتفاق النووي وايران رفضت ذلك
العرض وهناك نقاش
هل تقبل ام لا تقبل هذا العرض ولا من
تقبله في نهايه المطاف لحد الان
والمليشيات الايرانيه هاجمت الولايات
المتحده قبل اشهر وقتلت متعاقد امريكي وقد
قتلت القوات المليشيات
وودتنا هذا هذه لعبه خطره التوجيه
التهديدات ضد الولايات المتحده ان ان
سبق ان هدد الولايات المتحده انتهى به
المطاف بالندم
اذا قلنا ان هناك انشغالا امريكيا
هل تعتقد ان انشغالا كهذا يمكن ان يؤذي
بطرفين اذا ما تحدثنا عن ايران واسرائيل
الى نقطه
اللا عوده
اذا كان الامريكيون قلقون او مشغلينه حول
البرنامج النووي الايراني عليهم ان يعودوا
الى الاتفاق النووي السيد بايدن كان في
منصب الرئاسه منذ اكثر من سنتين وهو ما
يزال يماطل الحكومه الامريكيه كانت تقول
انهم يريدون لا يريدون العوده الى الاتفاق
بسبب المظاهرات في ايران وقد مرت اربع
اشهر او خمسه اشهر بدون اي مظاهرات في
ايران بالتالي هم فقط ياتون بالعذار في كل
يوم وهذا مؤشر على انهم ليسوا جادين حقا
او ليسوا قلقين حول مساله ايران وبنائها
لسلاح نووي لانه اذا ما كان القلق حقيقي
فهذا الامر سيجعلهم يرجعون الى طاوله
المفاوضات فورا هل
ستنعش الولايات المتحده مسارات دبلوماسيه
وعمل سياسي يحاول ان يتفادى اي حرب كهذه
امس سيحاول ان يستثمر في لغه الوعيد
الاسرائيلي
نحو تخفيض التصعيد والولايات المتحده
حاولت العوده لاتفاق النووي ولم يكن هناك
اتفاق جرد توصل اليه لم يتوصل لحد الان
والمفاوضات لكن لم تمت لحد الان فمن اسمع
تقارير بان ايران قد تقبل بعض المقترحات
الايرانيه وان الولايات المتحده قد تقدم
مقترحات جديده الموضوع غير ميت ولكن
توقعات فيه منخفضه جدا فهناك سنوات سنتان
من
المحادثات دون التوصل للاتفاق والاتفاق
عاطل لحد الان غير قد يتعلق بولايات
المتحده لم يلغيه الاوروبيون او
الايرانيون والايران بانما تزال ملتزمه
بهذا الاتفاق رغم انهم يمسعون برنامجهم
النووي الولايات المتحده دائما تسعى نحو
تخفيف التصعيد ولا تسعى الى
تشجيع النساءات لكن ايران سمحت لانف نفسها
ان تتصرف كما فعل بوتين الذي يؤدي الى قلق
في واشنطن فان هذا يعتبر مصدر خطر رئيسي
بان ايران انضمت الى جانب حرب بوتين في ضد
اوكرانيا
ولايه المتحده تساعد اوكرانيا لالحاق
الهزيمه بروسيا والسيد بوتين الان اسف
ونادم لانه غزى اوكرانيا سيد اسدي راينا
مناوره لحزب الله في اي سياق نضعها هل
ستنقل الحرب الى داخل الاسرائيلي بما
يعنيه ذلك من خطوره وهل ترى ان هناك حربا
وشيقه وشيكه ام سيظل الامر
تراشقا اعلاميا بتصريح هنا وتصريح هنا
لدينا دقيقه ونصف
مناورات لمنظمه مثل الحزب الله امر طبيعي
هم لديهم جناحه عسكري وينخرطونه في هذه
المناورات ويريدون ان يبقوا على اهبه
الاستعداد بالتالي هو امر طبيعي لهم
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبسبب صعوبات التي
تواجهها داخليا في الماضي قد كانت قد
انخرطت في
المواجهات وبدء المعارك خارج
حدودي فلسطين المحتله والسيد نتنياهو مجرم
حرب بالتالي بامكاننا ان نتوقع اي شيء من
شخص مثل نتنياهو لكن مهاجمه ايران بشكل
مباشر لا اعتقد ان هذا الامر سيحدث قريبا
لكن هو يحاول ان يشتج الانتباه يشدد
انتباه الصهاينه عن بصراع خارجي يتوقعونه
شكرا جزيلا لكم من طهران الدكتور فؤاد
ازدي استاذ الدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه في جامعه طهران ومن واشنطن
الدكتور كانت كوتشمان كبير الباحثين في
معهد صوفان للدراسات الاستراتيجيه والامن
الدولي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]